so here's this guy he's very funny but
who is he well you know he's 31 years
old he's from South Africa
you know he's speaks six different
languages and you know either is swiss
his mother so he grew up in an
interracial home where you know his
parents marriage was illegal at the time
his birth in South African so we just so
a lot of humor is is racially based as
ethnically based and you know you know
and they call him a polyglot he speaks a
lot of different languages and you look
at late night and so much importance is
now based on the second screen and the
ability to attract audience is not just
in the US but online around the world
that what this move is all about you of
you oh yeah yeah you know NBC said 70%
of Jimmy Fallon's views is online you
know and we're talking about before
about James
you know cordoning and how everyone saw
his Tom Hanks you know yeah and you know
why do that was taken over the show
after David Letterman yeah yeah he's was
thinking after Craig Ferguson and Claire
will replace Letterman in September I
saw James Corden driving around Mariah
Carey it was Tom Hanks and to see that
that video about how he got there and
all the stars Meryl Streep that were in
that video
Paul what do you make of kind of the
type of host that we're seeing in
late-night well I mean you know even
though for Jimmy Fallon that that stat
about 70% of the viewing coming online
the reality is the vast majority of the
revenue comes on over-the-air and so
it's big bucks and Comedy Central's
taking a big risk here by bringing a
century an unknown named talent
certainly to us audiences to a chair
that's just been a huge moneymaker for
Comedy Central for Viacom over the years
so it's a very gutsy move they're really
making a bet on a new fresh talent as
opposed to maybe going to safer route
and getting a more household name or
taking someone Jon Stewart was a no-name
when he for him to kind of get well you
know I think what John said he's not in
17 years would really put Jon Stewart
over the top was a study in 2005 from
Pew Research that said young adults are
getting their political news from Jon
Stewart they're not getting it from from
newscasts or cable or newspapers or
radio and
once you saw that number that that
statement his numbers real really
started to grow and I thought took him a
while I thought it was interesting
though that they didn't pick a woman
here you would have thought there was
more of a push for that and they had
such a huge talent pool right baby
I love her they have Jessica Williams
there's Olivia Munn I mean there's even
Tina Fey was mentioned and you know a
lot of people we've had a lot of
turnover and then the late night hosts
over the last couple of years and
there's been opportunities for a woman
to be given you know one of those big
chairs and they have not so that is
clearly an issue I think of some of the
networks have been on the defensive
about but here was another opportunity
to maybe fill that and they chose not to
do they not think women are funny do
women not resonate as funny Samantha bee
has actually gone to TBS I mean she's
got her own show you know Chelsea
Handler's now left II last August and
she's got a show on Netflix
of course late night doesn't mean much
of Netflix right but you know so she's
going over there and you know Jessica
Williams said on Twitter you know she's
about 25 years old she's very funny but
she said I don't think I'm ready for
this is it also thinking that Trevor
Noah is kind of a more global person and
so it plays to the global audience is
that part of it I think there's some of
the some of the digital rights that but
they're probably talking about it is
they think about maybe taking this show
you know a little bit to more global
audience through some of the digital
platforms that might resonate a little
bit more but again most of the economics
are from you know the traditional
over-the-air broadcast at least for the
next several years and that you know in
and of itself represents a risk for
Comedy Central but we might turn back
and look back in a year to and say this
was a bold move you know how important
is this as far as as far as revenue is
concerned I mean this is know top gear
right they're not know this is they're
not pulling in faff a billion dollars a
year
yeah no I mean you're an average unit
costs around $30,000 for a 30-second ad
I mean you know that that's that's a
pretty good number your thing also is
that the audience for The Daily Show is
younger and it's mal you know these are
lighter views of television you look at
the broadcast shows they're in their
fifties the more female so you know
you're going out reaching advert you
know an audience that advertisers really
want to reach because they're lighter
view is the TV and you throw in the
streaming you know the Monday
morning as Paul said it's not being you
know you can't really make money off of
that Jess Shepard you know he's 31 years
old by the time you reach this Jon
Stewart's age of 52 they'll find a way
to make money off of the screaming
there's too many viewers too many
important viewers for them not to when
you look at late-night right now who's
doing the best well Jimmy Fallon
yeah he's got about the close to 4
million viewers each night and then you
know Kimmel and Letterman are pretty
much tied you know I think that David
let him in finale sometime in May is
gonna do a huge number you know that's
not really getting a lot of press yet
but yeah anyway yeah you know he's
stepping down May 20th he's been on
behind the desk for 33 years longer than
Johnny Carson and I think that'll do
about 20 million viewers when it's all
said and done that that Alou a strong
number it's gotten very competitive in
late-night everybody on the broadcast
networks the cable networks all have a
late-night Frant franchise and now some
of the you know the some of the over the
top net networks are thinking about it
as well so there are there are ad
dollars there and it's gotten very
competitive so off to see how the you
know this replacement does I miss Johnny
Carson